free agency has indeed begun in effect
and a man who is in the middle of it all
who just negotiated Antonio Browns
contract with the Oakland Raiders and
has so much more going on kind enough to
fit in a few minutes for us right now
rosin house here on the rich highs are
you doing drew doing well rich sorry if
there's any background noise but it's
it's a hectic time with with free agency
and everything but but for you always
glad to talk for a few minutes here
appreciate it thank you so let's get
right to it
when did actually things begin to get
real between Antonio you and the Raiders
drew really on on Fridays things heated
up on Friday evening and Steelers
reached out to me and said that they'd
written agreement with the Raiders on
compensation and then they gave the
Raiders permission to talk to me I spoke
with one of your good friends mike
Mayock
and also Jon Gruden at length about
their wanting to finalize the trade for
Antonio but they knew like every other
team in the league day we sought a
revised contract we wanted to make sure
that Antonio for the rest of this
contract would be the highest-paid
receiver in the league and that that was
something that needed to be addressed
otherwise they would you know inherit
some of the issues that that we had with
some of the other teams so that's when
negotiations began and mike Mayock did a
heck of a job he was really a good
negotiator and after a lot of discussion
and back-and-forth were able to agree on
a number very early on Sunday mornings
so when it all came on Sunday morning
that's when the number finally came to
really my recollection is it was after
midnight I want to say Saturday night or
Sunday morning you know it was probably
around just after midnight on Sunday
morning ok so when it all comes down to
it drew I mean
where did the money rank in terms of
importance because it seems that
sometimes money was viewed as respect by
Antonio and obviously seeing how the
Steelers were on occasion making a
contractual maneuvers with him to try
and stay away from renegotiating with
multiple years left on his contract
where did this all come down to it in
terms of importance I think it was a
combination of things one you know which
it was evident after meeting with the
Steelers in South Florida a couple weeks
ago that included art ruining the team
owner and Kevin Kohlberg the G animals
myself and Antonio that both parties
agreed it would be in everyone's best
interest to move forward with the trade
once we got to that point it was clear
to us that it would be important for
Antonio to get with the a great
organization an outstanding coach
preferably a great offensive mind
somebody that you know would know how to
take advantage of Antonio's tremendous
talents and also terrific quarterback
because as your receiver you're limited
if you don't have a coach that you know
can can help get the ball to you and B
obviously you gotta have a quarterback
that can deliver and then you know
Antonio's had such a great run with the
Steelers and the Steelers really are one
of the one of the classic franchises in
the league with all their championships
and Hall of Famers and their birth care
organizations that can compare to them
and certainly the Raiders are right up
there with them
it's silver and black and Al Davis and
the incredible tradition that the
Raiders have all of those things really
made this a great fit for Antonio and
Jon Gruden is you know one of the
greatest offensive minds I think in the
history of professional football and
this will be a thrill to match a be up
with them and a super talented franchise
quarterback in David Carr
so quick hitters for you on this
did Jon Gruden and Antonio speak before
dotted lines or t's were crossed and I's
dotted they did okay at any point what
once once the clean was given permission
to communicate we made those
arrangements okay
did did you at any point ask if David
Carr was going to be Derek Carr was
going to be the quarterback of the
Raiders I didn't specifically asked but
it was evident in our discussions they
involved him throughout the process he
was mentioned politically by the Raiders
and he was also in touch with Antonio I
I'm I'm assuming that that will be
Antonio's quarterback moving forward but
of course we don't have any control over
that and that would just be our
assumption moving forward a few more
minutes
oh sure okay and your hope and a couple
more minutes left with Drew Rosenhaus
best you can tell did a Antonio Brown
and Big Ben have a conversation to see
if any anything between the two of them
could be hashed out to avoid all of this
I'm not sure if they did it's not
something that I discussed with the
Antonio and let me just backtrack a
little bit
you know once once the Steelers gave us
permission to negotiate with Oakland I
don't have first-hand knowledge of
Antonio and coach Gruden talking but I
was under the impression there was some
kind of communication I just don't know
specifically if there was and what
whether it was texting or he was
third-party or whether they spoke
directly and I never really discussed
that with Payne tonyia and finishing up
a conversation on on on Antonio how
aware were you of Antonio's social media
postings prior to the postings mr. big
chest it's all true you know I mean it
you know Antonio knows he doesn't he
doesn't you know he he obviously is
someone that is an actor I mean with his
fans
on social media he's had a great
presence on it we typically don't
discuss those things
I'm not directly involved if he calls me
and that's my opinion I'll share it with
them but you know certainly I follow
everything that he does and you know at
the end of the day rich we're in a good
spot I mean you know quite frankly he
made history here's a man that you know
things fell apart with the Steelers and
everyone agreed that it would be best to
move on he was able to do that and land
with the new team that has a great
attraction and now he is you know once
again the highest paid receiver in the
National Football League yeah I mean
we're when we did his last contract two
years ago and you know this thing
couldn't work out any better for us on
all levels right and he'll always love
the fans in Pittsburgh
and you know what rich I'm sure that
there will be amending of the fences at
some point later in Antonio's career
with with the Steelers and and the
people involved well in terms of in
terms of that with the contract for
rosenhouse how do you think this is
sitting with the rest of the National
Football League because you know as you
said history was made for sure three
years left on a deal 30-year old guy he
is posting things on on social media
that is perceived by many as disruptive
we we still don't really know what did
happen in week 17 he does have a
nine-year Hall of Fame resume there's no
question about it and an unquestioned
work ethic for many of his teammates to
say but all that said he got paid he got
the exit visas he wanted with a multiple
year contract still sitting on the table
how do you think this is sitting in the
rest of the National Football League oh
you know rich I think it's going to
hopefully have a very positive impact on
the National Football League
one thing is an agent that I'm a huge
believer in I've had discussions with
the NFL PA about this and they're very
supportive is you know we're always
looking for more flexibility in the
ability to read ago
and she trades it it should be more of a
two-way street in the NFL you know
you'll see a litany of players that just
sign new contracts two years ago look
just in Detroit they let TJ Lang and
Nevin Lawson go I think it was last year
that lost and signed a new deal and two
years before that TJ Lang that's just a
small example of instances where teams
commit the contracts with guys and then
let them go I mean what's in that long
ago that we did a big deal for Tammy
Jernigan with the Eagles and the Eagles
decided not to pick up his option hey
listen that's that's fair play I'm in
discussions with teams right now about
players that just a free agent contracts
that are either gonna have to take a pay
cut we're going to be released if that's
okay then why is it alright for a player
like Antonio who we feel has
outperformed his present deal and
uncomfortable with his current team to
seek a better circumstance if teams can
do it why can't players so you know
listen this is prevalent in in the NBA
and and and I think it's great if more
players and agents can follow our lead
and do what we did with a B and what a B
is accomplished with other with other
teams and other players last one for you
how's Gronk going into this very crucial
all offseason period what's his status
do you think you know I spoke with him
recently he's feeling good and got me
selfie thank God you know I got banged
up in the Super Bowl II played through a
quad injury he's he's one of a kind I
don't know what he's going to do he last
time I talked to him he had made a
decision up yet not sure what what that
decision is going to be whatever he
decides obviously he'll have my full
support I know that he's been in touch
with the organization they're supporting
him they're giving him the time that he
needs to make this calling
hopefully Rob will you know will be very
comfortable with his decision and I just
said to him take your time man
makes a decision that's best for you
don't rush into anything and think you
through and then do what you think is
best so that situation is still up in
the air rich hey drew I really
appreciate the time really busy time for
you wanted to pick up the phone
obviously with a huge piece of news that
you were involved in over the weekend
and just having been at it as long as I
have you've been at it longer I'm I'm
kind of wondering but back in the day of
T oh if there was social media if he
would have been able to get an Antonio
Brown situation in the same way that
Antonio just got you never know man you
never know you it's been a privilege for
me to to work for guys and negotiate on
behalf of hall-of-famers like like
Terrell and and of course a future Hall
of Famer in Antonio so great talking to
you right back at you hopefully one day
you'll be in the Hall of Fame as well I
don't know I don't know if I'll be
suiting up but other than just by once
at the combine rich yeah if you ever
need an agent to represent you I see
your 40 times they're getting faster and
faster I'm here for you man I love what
you do and thanks for all the work on
behalf of your charity you know as a guy
that goes to the combine every year I
watch a lot of forties that mean a lot
to me in terms of how it affects our
clients but there's no more important 40
out there than the one that you run
every year and yet my admiration for the
hey man I appreciate it drew thanks so
much let's stay in touch and have a good
free agent period you bet that's Drew
Rosenhaus of rosenhouse sports here on
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience